Voiceover:So this kind of
hairy looking expression,
we're just dividing one complex number,
written in blue, by
another complex number.
This first complex - actually,
both of them are written in polar form,
and we also see them plotted over here.
This first complex number, seven times,
cosine of seven pi over six,
plus i times sine of seven pi over six,
we see that the angle,
if we're thinking in polar
form is seven pi over six,
so if we start from
the positive real axis,
we're gonna go seven pi over six.
So we're gonna go seven pi over six,
all the way to that
point right over there.
And then from the origin,
we're going to step seven out,
or seven away from the origin.
So one, two, three, four, five, six, seven
to get to that point right over there.
And then the second number,
the angle is seven pi over four.
So that takes us all the way around here.
It takes us all the way -
so I should do it smaller
since that has a smaller distance,
so let me - so let's
say we start over here,
so we're going to go all the way over here
to that point right over here,
and it's distance from the origin is one.
You can imagine that there's
a one in front of that.
And we want to divide the two,
and I encourage you to
pause this video and
try to do this on your own,
and then plot the resulting
number when you divide
this blue complex number
by this green one.
Well, as you might have realized,
if you somehow just try
to divide it straight up,
it can get quite hairy,
and the way to tackle it,
is to write it in another form.
And what might have jumped out at you is
that exponential form would
be much, much simpler.
And the way that we convert
this to exponential form
is to recognize that this
business right over here
is the same thing, this comes straight out
of Euler's formula, this is
e, to the seven pi over six i.
Seven pi over six i.
That's this expression right over here.
So this entire top complex
number can be rewritten
as seven e, to the seven pi over six i.
And this bottom complex
number can be rewritten
as one times, we didn't
really have to write the one,
but this bottom part
right over here is going
to be the same thing as e,
to the seven pi over four i.
Seven pi over four i,
and this comes straight
out of Euler's formula.
And when you write it in
this way, then we can just
use exponent properties to simplify it.
We have the same base, and
so we can just subtract
this exponent from that
exponent right over there.
So this is going to be equal to seven
divided by one, is just seven.
So it's going to be seven
to the, or seven times e.
Let me do this in a brighter color.
Seven times e, to the seven pi over six i,
minus seven pi over four i.
Minus seven pi over four ith power.
So what is this going to be equal to?
Well if I have seven pi
over six of something
and I subtract seven pi
over four of that thing,
how many do I have left over?
Well, let's see, I'm essentially -
let's just rewrite all of this.
This is really just about
subtracting fractions at this point.
So if I were to rewrite this, let's see,
if I were to rewrite it
with a denominator of 12,
then I'll have a common denominator.
It's my least common
multiple of six and four.
So this one I can rewrite
as 14 pi i over 12.
Or I can write it as 14 pi
i over 12, and then minus -
so I multiplied the
numerator and denominator
by three, minus 21 pi i over 12, as well.
Right? I just multiplied numerators
and denominators by three right over here.
And so this is going to be equal to,
I'm going to have, 12 in the denominator,
14 pi i, minus 21 pi i,
is going to be negative seven pi i.
So, this thing is equal to seven e,
to the negative seven pi i, over 12.
Now let's see if we can do a
decent job of plotting this.
So let's see, each of these increments
that they've done, in
each of these quadrants,
we have one, two, three, four, five, six.
So they split this quadrant
into six equal angles,
and this quadrant is pi over two,
so each of these are pi over 12.
Each of these little
subangles are pi over 12.
So we're going to have
negative seven pi over 12.
So we're going to go in
the negative direction.
We're going to go
counter-clockwise, or sorry,
we're going to go clockwise.
So we're going to go, let me start here,
so if I go one, two, three,
four, five, six, seven,
eight, nine, 10, 11, 12,
gets us right over there.
Did I do that right? That
doesn't - let me make sure
I got that - negative seven,
so each of these are pi
over - let me make sure.
So this whole thing is
pi, so we have one -
let me make sure, this whole thing is pi.
We have one, two, three, four, five, six,
seven, eight, nine, 10, 11, 12.
So each of these are a twelfth of that,
so it's pi over 12, that's right.
Then we want to go negative seven of them.
Negative one, negative
two, negative three,
negative four, negative
five, negative six,
negative seven, oh ya, I just kept going
all the way to negative 12 the last time.
So this is the angle, this
is our angle right over here.
And our distance that we
go out from the origin
is seven, so we go out
one, two, three, four,
five, six, seven, so we
come out right over there.
So this complex number divided by that
complex number is equal
to this complex number,
seven times e, to the
negative seven pi i over 12.
And if we wanted to now write this
in polar form, we of course could.
We could say that this is the same thing
as seven, times cosine of
negative seven pi over 12,
plus i sine of negative seven pi over 12.